[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with newfound
freedom for brittany spears the pop star
describing the end of her long-fought
13-year conservatorship battle with her
father in just three words best day ever
as carter evans reports there were
celebrations outside the courthouse in
los angeles for the crowning moment of
that what's become the free britney
movement
it is
of britney spears
victory for britney spears hundreds of
her loyal fans erupted into cheers
outside the courthouse after hearing
news that a judge ended spears 13-year
conservatorship meaning the pop star
will again be in control of her life i'm
just so happy she could get her life
back minutes after the decision spears
posted this message on instagram good
god i love my fans so much it's crazy i
think i'm going to cry the rest of the
day
spears's fiance posted this video on
instagram the 39 year old wore a free
britney t-shirt
i think the biggest challenge that she's
going to face is making sure that she
finds people that are trustworthy
spears who is worth nearly 60 million
dollars hired an accountant with her
attorney who now manages her finances
last month the judge removed britney
spears father jamie spears as her
conservator we've been hoping for this
for so long earlier this summer spears
told the court the conservatorship under
her father was abusive and that he and
others in charge should be in jail she
alleged that she was forced to work
against her will and to use a
contraceptive device to prevent her from
having any more children through his
attorney jamie spears has repeatedly
denied all allegations of wrongdoing
britney spears attorney has vowed to
investigate her father jamie spears and
others
are going to face even more serious
ramifications for cbs saturday morning
carter evans los angeles
we're just talking it's the story been
following for
years yeah i i honestly didn't start
following it until it made sort of news
national news and then i saw like you
said the new york times documentary yeah
you're like what this has been happening
and the reflection on how the media
coverage was of people and performers
like britney spears young women in
particular really in this day and age i
mean obviously it does not hold up well
so you can see how so many people were
so moved by her story and they said in
the beginning a lot of legal experts
were saying it was unlikely that this
conservatorship would be
dissolved and then it all sort of
happened pretty quickly yeah it did